Virtual Conferences.
They put us in the position
to do what we have not done before,
which is giving a pre-recorded talk.
This video has 7 tips for you on how to
improve your pre-recorded videos, enjoy!
For a researcher, there are
three key points for success:
The ability of speaking, writing and
the values of the presented ideas.
But since you are interested in this topic
of recording talks for a virtual conference,
I assume the two points below are no
problem for you: You just got a written
paper accepted for its valuable ideas. So
this video, will be about the first point,
specifically about your ability to speak and
record a talk for a virtual presentation.
I know, research conferences are drawing us
researchers from various corners of the earth and
for many of us, English is not a native language.
This is one more reason to speak slowly enough and
most importantly, clearly. Less like this, because
Iam going to talk about my work [unitelligible],
and more like, this:
"Hello there, my name is Letitia Parcalabescu and
I am going to talk to you about Multimodality."
The second point I am going
to talk about, is... smiling!
You are presenting your work that
just got accepted at a conference,
so please do not speak like you are
attending a funeral [funeral song].
Smile a little and this will
not only enlighten your face,
but also your voice will become more pleasant.
Camera specifications are not exactly
the most important issue here,
because nobody wants to see
all your pores on your face.
But very important is your camera's position.
Many of us record with the laptop camera.
This delivers the perfect angle for
the viewer to inspect your nostrils!
Keep in mind to place the camera aligned
to your face to deliver an optimal result.
Not everyone has a podcast microphone,
but consider buying one!
Kidding, kidding!
But whatever microphone you plan to use, do
not choose the oldest iPhone headset lying
around in your home, but consider buying a new
one and spending 40€ for a better microphone.
No, they do not pay me for this.
It will help you with recording but also in the
numerous Zoom meetings one needs to attend these
days. If your microphone does not have always a
white noise or a peeping sound attached to it,
people will be involuntarily less
disturbed when you are speaking to them!
If your voice and audio are pleasant,
people will be pleasant to you!
Not all of us are perfect public
speakers and while recording a video,
there is also no audience hearing you right then.
The lack of audience will not deliver you the
adrenaline that would flow on
a stage while speaking live.
So the concentration is of course reduced
while recording. This is why, instead of
doing N attempts until you do it all right,
consider doing a minimum of cutting the video.
Software like kdenlive is very easy to use
and available for all operating systems!
Possibly an alternative to post-editing
is the compilation of a script to which
you either stick closely or even read from. But it
is very important to do 2 things
if you are working with a script:
Don't write it like you would write a paper,
but write it like you would explain
to a colleague what you are doing.
Otherwise, your audience will have
a hard time understanding you.
Secondly, do not forget to interpret this script,
say it like you mean it, like
you would perform in theatre.
And the last tip I have for you:
Relax, if you start some time in advance
before the video hand-in deadline,
you have a lot of time to
do it until you do it right.
And if you are post-editing, do not hesitate
to do it all in one imperfect cut, and then,
and then repeat the bad parts, and
repeat bad parts like nothing happened,
because you will remove
these in post-editing anyway!
I really hope that this video
helps you record better videos.
I am really curious to read about
your experience in the comments!
Do not forget to hit the
like and subscribe buttons
and see you next time!
Ok bye!